[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
perfect phone calls absolutely 100
no crime committed
make phone calls ah there's more there's
more recordings
there's more recordings of him and also
the um the members of the grand jury in
Georgia say that if you saw the evidence
if you saw the evidence
there would be no division in this
country I actually do not believe that
um apparently there's news that the the
grand jurors
um that recommended indictments for over
a dozen
um trumpetites probably Trump included
and say that if you saw the evidence
they saw which apparently there's
another phone call with the
uh with the speaker of the house in the
Georgia legislator uh trying to get him
to call a special session to steal away
the election from the Georgia voters and
the American people
by crowning Donald Trump King in Georgia
for whatever the hell that means listen
this is all really
um
I think I guess the question is who goes
first what's on second I don't know
who's on third who goes first is it
Georgia or the Manhattan D.A uh it
doesn't appear that Jack Smith is within
Striking Distance but with Stormy
Daniels and Michael Cohen testifying in
front of the grand jury in the Manhattan
DA's office
um that criminal grand jury probe into
the um the illegal payment that that
breaks campaign Finance laws the bribe
as it were and we watched the tape of
the attorney yesterday trying to grab
Ari melber by the receipts of Trump's
lies you remember this
um
that's the best way I can describe it I
don't know what to tell you uh it it
seems that the Manhattan D.A is within
Striking Distance here of coming to the
conclusion that yes he committed
felonies and yes it's a crime and the
grand jury is probably going to indict
him and we see uh Georgia
with some of these reports of the grand
jury and with the evidence that is laid
before us
um
probably within Striking Distance as
well now you have to remember these are
State charges
um so he'll have to
be extradited to those states to be
arraigned he's not going to go to those
States willingly I would imagine which
only increases the war between meatball
pudding or putting meatball and we're
going to talk about putting meatball
today that's right he's got a new
nickname putting meatball Ron Ronnie
tiny d
a Santos that's right
he apparently likes to eat pudding with
his fingers I I don't tell you these
[__] are weird what do you want me to
do
I keep telling you this I I I
don't I don't provide the content that I
have to commentate on this is just
it's a weird timeline anyways uh back to
the problem in hand Ronnie D down in
Florida will have to extradite Trump so
he'll have to give up Trump or he won't
give up Trump you know I don't I don't
know
um I would say that since Donald Trump's
campaign is suing uh Rhonda Santos
that maybe Ronnie D might give him up I
didn't think you would
but maybe he will
I mean this is weird [__] we're living
through folks
because he's got to be arraigned right
so just because he's charged uh with
crimes in in the Manhattan DA's office
through the grand jury or through the
grand jury in Florida with these State
charges uh doesn't mean he'll be
incarcerated it could I mean it could
mean that but I seriously doubt that
I really seriously doubt that a judge is
going to incarcerate him in Georgia or
New York while he's waiting on a trial
for criminal charges either place
now the difference between the case and
the Manhattan DA's office and I'm no
[__] lawyer you know that you know
that
but I'm just going off of politics here
right so the case in the Manhattan DA's
office is a direct aim at Donald Trump
himself right I mean his co-conspirator
was Michael Cohen and Michael Cohen is
the key witness against Donald Trump in
this case
and the reason why Michael Cohen isn't a
target of the actual probe is because
he's already served Federal time for
that crime
so the state wouldn't
exactly prosecute him they're using him
as the key witness as his co-conspirator
in the effort to pay Stormy Daniels
to cover up that he had sex with her
what do you want from me that's the
story he had sex with Stormy Daniels he
didn't want to get it out before the
election and he paid her off
now yesterday we watched the uh we
watched Trump's good attorney this is
supposed to be the one that's
is good I don't know I Define good
attorney anymore really honestly I mean
Jesus Christ and we've had attorneys
here on the show Karen agneppel go
agnipolo from legal AF Michael popock
and Ben mizellis from legal AF might as
touch legal AF
um but you know I it
and I'm sure they're out there but they
don't exist in Trump's Universe right
this this guy was supposed to be the
good attorney
and he clearly is gaslighting Ari melber
who is a good attorney by the way
um on air and all of Ari's audience
saying that Trump didn't lie when
obviously it was a lie
which is not surprising with Trump
but
um
the Manhattan DA's office it seems that
uh Trump is the target the only target
the aim is him and the felonies that he
would have committed with this payment
to Stormy Daniels in the Georgia case
much different
much more layered case I mean we're
going to see people we've never heard of
indicted
and likely the likelihood is that
um the grand jury the criminal grand
jury that is convened to try to um take
the recommendations of their other grand
jury to press charges and indict
um
they're going to have to try to get
these other folks probably state
legislators maybe the Speaker of the
House of Georgia the former Speaker of
the House of Georgia I actually I think
he's dead and he is he [__] dead hmm
and they say Hillary Clinton kills
people anyways anywho there's your
conspiracy theory to spend on the
internet
um here's the thing is that they're
probably going to get these people to
flip and cooperate and they're probably
going to because State Prison just isn't
a fun thing especially in Georgia I mean
Jesus Christ you think Rikers bad
imagine the state prisons in Georgia I
don't I don't believe that they're
probably like uh five-star hotels that
would be my guess and it's not like a
camp fed uh so these people aren't
really probably going to want to be
indicted on state charges go to court
and receive several years in a state
penitentiary in Georgia so and
especially if they're elected officials
or former elected officials which I
think is what we're going to see we're
going to see people we've never heard of
that's going to be the biggest
difference like the Manhattan DA's case
when they indict like yep that makes
sense and we know we know the crime
Michael Cohen has told us the crime
Michael Cohen went to court for the
crime individual one was the
co-conspirator which is Donald Trump
everyone [__] knows that this isn't
it isn't like a big huge guessing game
here in the Manhattan DA's office the
only thing we're waiting on is what are
the actual charges
and what is the evidence against him
that I mean that's that I mean what what
is it that's the substance of it that
the Manhattan D.A is presenting to the
grand jury that they'll indict and what
charges will they indict on now in
Georgia it's a whole different [__]
ball of wax we're not talking about a um
a campaign Finance law breaking the law
there
this is this is [__] election
tampering that we're talking about
because apparently there's a phone call
there's a phone another [__] phone
call is he up to three or four perfect
phone calls or is it five is it five
perfect phone calls is that how many
we're doing now
um so apparently there's another phone
call where he called the speaker of the
house at the time the Speaker of the
House of Georgia the Georgia legislator
and was trying to get the speaker of the
house to convene a special session to
steal the election
um commit election tampering and give
the election to him and not Joe Biden
so there's more perfect perfect phone
calls
and this is what I've been telling you
the whole time he projects always
projects remember when he's been
tweeting well excuse me posting on fraud
social
about two perfect phone calls we're like
well we know the one with raster Burger
we know the one what's what's the what's
the other one well here we are
always projecting always with this [__]
he knows what crimes he's committed
folks he knows what crimes he's probably
going to be indicted on his attorneys
are telling him this
I mean they're seeing the discovery
they're getting to participate in some
of these grand juries and some of this
testimony
I mean the Jack Smith case even he knows
especially the documents
with more than likely the obstruction
charge of what he's going to get charged
with
this isn't this isn't a big [__]
secret
I mean we don't know exactly what is
being said and what evidence is being
brought I mean we don't know all the
evidence
we got a damn good idea and the person
that provides us the most evidence there
is
that [__] Cheeto dust Q anoner
himself
always telling on himself
now
let's say he gets indicted let's walk
this through a bit
um because I want to get to for a few
minutes here in the first 30 minutes in
the a block it is before we go to break
I want to get to
um this um this uh birth control excuse
me abortion pill and abortion services
that this uh Trump appointed Texas
federal judge is going to try to strip
away from all women in this country and
I want to tell you why I was telling you
just [__] shut up about Walgreens
okay I was I'm gonna tell you why I was
saying that okay I was right I was
correct again
as normal
so but let's let's smoke this Trump
thing out because everyone's concerned
about his incarceration and again I keep
telling you this is only going to
heighten his status among the cult
uh and maybe I should bring a cult
expert on maybe Dr Hassan or someone uh
to to confirm this
but when a cult leader is in trouble the
majority of the cult actually
you know circles the wagons as it were
to protect the cult leader and it's only
going to propel him to the nomination
everyone knows he's going to get the
nomination even Rhonda Santos at this
point with his visit to Iowa
and how it flopped and his little book
tour that he did how it [__] flopped
that his war on wokeism isn't selling
around the country
and everyone's not buying his [__]
but he's not that popular outside the
borders of Florida
um it's kind of like you remember
um Scott Walker you remember that guy he
was a governor he was a really he was
man and he was supposed to be the
president of the United States man I
mean this guy you remember Scott Walker
he was the governor of Wisconsin he
fended off recalls
um and he was supposed to be the
president then he went to Iowa and his
campaign just [__] folded like a
cheap umbrella
in Iowa just boom just like that
and Ronda Santa says the problem that he
can't actually have a campaign and be
the governor of Florida so he can't have
his cake and eat it too he can't be Mr
fashion leader
and Institute fascist policies and run
for president he's trying to change the
state law but we'll see how quickly that
happens Trump is already suing him over
that
but here's the thing if Ronda santis
does decide to extradite Donald Trump I
don't I still don't think we see him
incarcerated I think he's arraigned we
see uh maybe a perp walk at best uh kind
of like Steve Bannon but he's going to
be let loose
yeah after he's arraigned on these
charges and really he's going to be able
to delay delay delay
because he's getting enough [__]
boneheads like this attorney that went
on Ari Melbourne uh Alina Haba to stall
stall stall in court
and to get it pushed back until he can
win primaries because folks that's what
he's doing
he's betting that he's going to win some
primaries and when he wins primaries he
can convince a judge hey I'm running for
president
can't indict me and I think it'll work
that's right I believe it will work
as much as you don't want it to that I
mean what am I supposed to do I'm just
telling you what I believe is going to
happen
he's going to use his primary wins his
early primary wins uh to to do that to
make the argument in court that hey I'm
running for president you can't really
you can't incarcerate me we can't go to
trial because it's it'll be political
until after the election now even if he
were to do that it doesn't matter and
and the reason why is because no one can
save him a president can't save Donald
Trump from State charges in Georgia or
state charges in New York meaning if Joe
Biden were to win and then 2028 somehow
a republican would win and would pardon
him they can't pardon him from State
charges now I think that's the key here
with Georgia and the Manhattan D.A
really honestly that's why that those
indictments are so important but the
most important one is Jack Smith but I
still don't think we see this guy
incarcerated for a long time if at all
we'd never incarcerated a former
president goddamn we never charged a
former president with a crime ever
before in our history
I mean so I guess the question is how is
he incarcerated because he's going to
get indicted and he is [__] guilty
good luck [__] good luck [__] now I
want to um I want to make a few
announcements before I get to this um
Texas Trump appointed judge and tell you
why you talking about Walgreens
took the eye off the ball that's right
I'm going to chastise people who were
boycotting Walgreens
are you ready I told you this was a dumb
idea I told you it was bad messaging we
had Rachel bidikoffer on and we talked
about it but first the announcements I
believe Gabe Sanchez is going to be back
with us today he was back he sent the
thumbnail the art that you see that that
is the work of Gabe Sanchez so everyone
clap and cheer that gave chances is back
in business the problem is his power
went out so
um we're not sure exactly when he'll be
on the show but we're hoping to get him
on the show today so
um that's that's announcement number one
Gabe is back Gabe is back Gabe is back
so everyone uh cheering excitement and
we get him on today and we're going to
get him to tell us a little bit about
his vacation and where he was at and
what he got to see because I'm sure you
everyone's interested in exactly uh why
Gabe Sanchez was gone and then what he
was doing while he was gone on his uh
surely it was a Soros funded vacation to
some undisclosed uh antifa headquarters
somewhere I'm sure that's what it is
uh okay here's why here's why here's why
you made the mistake almost over a week
um and in in trying to boycott Walgreens
as Walgreens knew that this court uh
decision was coming soon and for this uh
drug and it appears that this federal
judge in Texas which they judge shopped
uh these anti-abortion anti-woman
and domestic terrorists that they are
trying to take away Women's Health Care
judge shopped and got the Trump judge
and it appears that they're going to
force the FDA this judge is going to
force the FDA to pull these drugs off
the shelf now last week when we talked
to rate Dr Rachel bidikoffer I said then
and Rachel agreed with me and we had a
conversation about it you can go back
and look at that at that episode
um and maybe I'll just post that [__]
that part of it and I guess I could cut
it find it cut it but here's what I'll
tell you is at the time we were saying
you can't blame Walgreens okay if you
want a boycott them boycott them but to
blame this on Walgreens is going to be a
mistake for our national narrative and
our national messaging listen hey
Democrats out there Jamie Harrison or
anyone else if you're if you're trying
or anyone in the house uh any kind of uh
group that wants some messaging how
about you come here first and you ask me
and then I'll tell you exactly why
you're making mistake or that's good
messaging because last week Walgreens
was the enemy in the fight for women's
rights and this week this week this week
it is clearly what I was saying it's not
Walgreens who is your enemy here it's
not Walgreens Walgreens is just going to
try to follow the law like doctors are
doctors in Texas aren't wanting to not
give women abortion Services they're not
able to
the doctors aren't the enemy here
these clinics aren't the enemy here
the people who are wanting to profit off
of a drug that is that is an abortion
service that by the way makes up most of
50 percent of abortion services in this
country this this one [__] drug
because because a house safe and how
effective it is in women's health care
regardless of what you believe is an
abortion or not or when Life Starts you
can [__] right off okay it's Women's
Health Care and you don't like it shut
the [__] up you don't have to have it
you do not have to take this drug no one
is holding you down you [__] white
males and making you take a drug that
isn't Women's Health Care not men okay
now when you were taking your eye off
the ball last week and yelling and
screaming about Walgreens and Walgreens
is bad and Walgreens that and Walgreen
that I'm even chastising uh Gavin Newsom
here you are losing track of what
matters most who is the [__] enemy of
women's health care it is not Walgreens
trying to take away Women's Health Care
it is it is not it is not doctors in
Texas trying to take away Women's Health
Care
it is Republicans it is fascist all
around the country that want to take
your [__] rights away from you
and until and until you identify who is
the problem you're not going to fix it
the fix is this we have to have a
national narrative and National
messaging that is in one one step in One
Direction we cannot be aiming at 50
different [__] things to try to make
sure we get we get rid of the problem
which the problem is people who want to
take away women's rights which are human
rights they want their Liberty
got it they want to control them
it's not hard to understand this
Walgreens has to follow the law
the FDA has to follow the law
they're not going to get outside of
those boundaries doctors who have
licenses
are not going to get outside the
boundaries of the law
now since the law is the problem we need
to fix who is legislating our [__]
laws and not only legislating our laws
but apparently
apparently
checking them with the judicial system
it is more important now than ever to
women's rights and human rights in
general to make sure that we as the left
as liberals as people who believe in
Liberty
understand who is the enemy of democracy
our rights our freedoms and our Liberty
Walgreens is not the enemy
the doctors who cannot provide care
because of the law are not the enemy
get it through your thick skulls I'm
talking I'm usually am yelling at
moglodytes but today I'm yelling at
liberals everywhere
pluck your head out of your ass and
understand that messaging and narrative
is the most important weapon we will use
from now until the end of 2024 right up
to the election
if you don't understand that if you
don't get that
we can lose our rights and our freedoms
for marginalized groups
women people of color the lgbtq
community because they're coming after
them
children they're trying to strip away
parents consent
in States
and if you don't if you don't get your
[__] head right
if you don't get your [__] head right
and understand what the foundation of
our democracy is
and make sure to to identify the enemy
of that Foundation
we will lose ground
we cannot afford to lose ground now
is the time to band together now is the
time to create a national narrative and
National messaging
and we can use that messaging to
encourage infighting inside their party
and inside their fascist movement to
destroy each other so that way when we
come around
when we have to gather up ballots in
this country to make sure to save our
democracy not just in the House of
Representatives not just in the Senate
not just in the executive branch
of our federal government
folks we have to work hard in these
State races we did it in 2022 Jesus
Christ we created a safety net
for our presidential election in 2022
by making sure in Pennsylvania in
Michigan in Wisconsin and Arizona
we didn't elect people who would steal
away the election the way that Donald
Trump was trying to do in Georgia
and other states
but looks like there's going to be
several indictments in Georgia for that
very thing
and if you don't believe
if you don't believe that our hard work
of national narrative and National
messaging against these fascists created
that safety net and that backstop
against these people stealing our
elections in 2024 you are a bonehead
great if you don't want to if you don't
want to patronize Walgreens fine if you
want to say boycott Walgreens fine
great whatever whatever you want to do
great great on you I'm just telling you
right now right here and I said it last
week
and I'm only being proven correct
today and tomorrow and next week and
whenever this decision comes down
because we know how the decision is
going to come down
women all around the country are not
going to have access to this drug
because everyone was concerned about
Walgreens not this case down in Texas
where this Trump appointed judge now we
have the chance for appeal
okay we have the chance for appeal but
it is likely
that this is going to ratchet its way up
to the Supreme Court
another fight
that we must win
we must win
because if they can so easily take away
such an effective piece of Health Care
away from women they will take effective
Health Care away from your children
they will hey hey guys hey dudes out
there
who don't use this drug that they'll
take away effective health care for you
too dummy
stop with the stupid battles that don't
matter
stop
doing it stop making memes about it
you're wasting your [__] time
there's only there's only one one enemy
of democracy here and it is the
Republican Nazis
you doubt me that Republicans are Nazis
because a bunch of Republicans showed up
in Wadsworth Ohio
protesting drag shows which is a
tenement of their personality right now
that they think drag is trans people and
somehow trans people are evil and they
need to be eradicated I'm not making
this [__] up
foreign if you think I'm making it up
you have your head up your ass
they're coming for you they're coming
for your family and they're using
marginalized communities including
women's health care including trans
People's Health Care including people's
rights to dress up and entertain
[__]
they're coming after you you may not
think well I mean I'm not trans I'm not
a woman I don't I don't dress up and
drag I don't go to drag shows my
children aren't in the lgbtq community
nor are they trans
I'm an ally though if you're an ally
then you stand for their [__] Liberty
too or yours is at risk
they will come for yours
you [__] doubt me
go read a goddamn book
from the 1920s to 1930s and the 1940s in
world history just go read that
[__] for a half a second
realize that this is not a new thing
it's not something that just oh well oh
this type of fascism just popped up out
of nowhere
there's a road map here and they're
trying to follow it now they're failing
miserably because they are nincompoop
Nazis
and they're failing because because
liberals in this country are getting
messaging correct
and people are banding together in our
democracy and we're going to use our
democracy democracy to save it not to
destroy it
the difference between this country and
Nazi Germany is we have a much stronger
fabric
it is a much different
set of Foundations here in this country
than post-world War One in Germany and
in Europe in general
remember that we have that working for
us but the thing that we can use the
most is our voices and our microphones
and this microphone is only one
you are thousands of microphones
thousands of them
but come here every single weekday and I
will tell you what the national
narrative in the National messaging must
be
I'll show you the way
you you doubt me on this but I was
correct about the Walgreens thing
and it's okay it's okay if if I'm if I'm
knocking you a little bit from last week
from maybe a Twitter post that you had
or something it's okay it's all right
you're forgiven
from here on out know who the [__]
enemy is
to our democracy
the enemy is not Joe Biden the enemy is
not the pro-democracy coalition
the enemy is at Walgreens who has to
follow the law
because Republicans are legislating laws
that take away people's [__] rights
know who the enemy of democracy is that
is how we win
everyone stick around we'll be right
back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
foreign
with the power problems
his first day back wouldn't you know it
wouldn't you know it
this power gets shut off what are you
gonna do what the hell are you gonna do
you can't do much without power so
you know what let's do this for a minute
let's shoot the [__] while we see if we
can get them if we can if we can get
we can get Gabe Sanchez on here
oh let's see we're gonna shoot the [__]
for just a second and then I'm gonna
show you some of these videos If Gabe
Sanchez doesn't make it because again a
lot of Clips I got a lot of Clips to
show you that's right we got Clips to
show you
um
so yeah I'll give me one second I'm
taking care taking care of business
taking care of business
um so we're gonna shoot the [__] so get
your questions in the um
in the chat there
okay uh Margie if you can hear me you
should be good you should be good she'll
know what I mean
and if not just I don't know message me
or or something hey we got to take care
of some business here first and then
we'll shoot the [__] so get your
questions in the uh the chat there right
there on Twitch YouTube Facebook get
your questions going there and I'll
answer a few of your questions the first
thing I want to say is thank you this
week for for uh buying up so many [__]
em hats they're they're [__] em hats
being in the mail right now there's so
many going out you guys have bought
dozens of [__] em hats and if you st and
we're gonna continue
um the [__] em hat week
up until Sunday so the promo code hats
10 hats 10. if you go to
thetonymichaels.com right the Tony
michaels.com and you go to [__] em hats
link it's just you just scroll down a
bit the [__] them hats merch store you
go click there
and um you'll be able to go to the hat
store and if you use the promo code
hats10
hats10 you can get 10 off your entire
purchase of [__] handsome boy you
guys really like the [__] man so go
to
go to tonymichaels.com that's
deeptonymichaels.com slide down hit the
hats The Buck Em hats link it'll take
you to the hat store and you can use the
promo code
hats10 while you're at
thetonymichaels.com don't forget to
follow us on all social media platforms
and platforms everywhere make sure you
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
here on YouTube make sure you follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google across all the platforms follow
us on Facebook at the Tony Michaels also
follow our show on the up wires YouTube
channel just go to the upwire.com or
follow us on Twitch did you know
did you know that if you have a Prime
subscription
you can actually
here's what you can do you can link it
to your Twitch account and what it does
is it gives you one free subscription
it gives you one free subscription
to Twitch and you can give that one free
subscription to the Tony Michaels
podcast and it gives us a few dollars of
Jeff bezos's money and you guys holy
moly there's been let me check here
there's been uh
there's almost 90. 90 people have linked
their account
uh to Amazon so go to
um link your Amazon.com or your Amazon
Prime account excuse me to your Twitch
account and give us that one free
subscription to support the show that
would be fantastic it doesn't cost you a
dime it doesn't really so thank you very
much for all your support and also we
have a goal of 250 patreon members we
are at 167 we're getting so close
um here to 250. you guys blew through
the 100
gold now 150 goal and we're gonna sit we
set the 250 goal
so go to go to patreon.com D Tony
Michaels or go to thetonymichaels.com
and click the patreon link and see what
we got going over on patreon I think
um probably tomorrow afternoon I think
that's what I plan on doing tomorrow
afternoon I'm going to do an ask me
anything it'll be a 30 minute session uh
on patreon only where you get to ask me
anything you want and I'll answer all
those questions so go to patreon.com D
Tony Michaels or D Tony michaels.com and
check out the patreon page if you want
to participate in the ask me anything I
believe I I really think we'll be able
to do it tomorrow afternoon I think I'm
gonna have time
um but we'll we'll see it is St Pat's
day but we'll see we'll we'll get that
going now let's see do we get any
questions here in the chat uh as we
shoot this [__] let's see
um okay so Vicky's got a question here
let me change my screen there we go so
we got the um
Vicki's got a question here I think wow
I get a lot of look here's the problem
um sometimes is I get all comments so
you guys and if you're in a chat right
and you're seeing uh comments in that
chat I see those plus everyone else's
here's Vicky's question Tony how do we
start the process to vote out all the
legislators state county state federal
that are responsible for these fascist
laws well what we do Vicky is we have a
national
narrative and messaging that is the only
way we're going to do it you know we've
always been lied to that politic
politics are local you're full of
[__] [__]
you're full of [__] how are politics
local if there is if there are people
who are using CRT and wokism to get on
County commissions to get on school
boards you think that's you think those
are local [__] narratives get the
[__] out of here
we are in we are in a different period
of time
this is not the period of time of the
local newspaper where everyone went
every evening to get their groceries and
grab the local newspaper and take it
home and read the local issues it's not
what is happening folks we are in a we
are in a information war and a
misinformation War
and they are Waging War on our country
not just uh from inside our country but
outside our country
and we have to and they've been doing
this for years they've been doing this
for decades and decades and decades to
put themselves in this position
they did it with uh right wing talk
radio with Rush Hannity
uh Mark Levin they've done it with Fox
News now on and Newsmax they've done it
with uh
uh the the Breitbart
um they've done it with online Rags
these right-wing online Rags now like
project Veritas those line sacks of [__]
uh and and on and on it goes and on and
on it goes but they have been creating
in the minds of these diluted little
ignorant moglodytes
this this National push
and it's worked it has worked folks
because it works
so we can't we can't just stand around
and go you know we don't want to be like
them and do what works no we want to do
what works and what works is get a
national narrative in the National
messaging
of [__] democracy of accountability
of responsibility it's ridiculous that
we can't do this
we can do this it's going to take a long
time to undo the damage
that the right wing has done to this
country
Mal agree it's not going to be easy it's
going to be long and hard but we have to
keep pushing I hope that answers that
question again okay
um Mitchell ask here
about Georgia which I was thinking about
earlier if I can get the comment come on
come on there it goes sorry
buttons aren't working I guess I don't
know now Mitchell Jones from YouTube
says do you think John Eastman will be
indicted in Georgia for the fake elector
scheme along with Arizona Nevada
Wisconsin and Michigan I mean
I'll tell you that that
um if the Georgia indictments from the
grand jury are successful in convictions
prosecutions and and incarcerations that
it may lay the groundwork for Arizona
Nevada Wisconsin Michigan and other
states
um we do know that in Arizona Rusty
Bowers the speaker of the house at the
time was pressured by Trump and his team
to do the same thing that this phone
call is perfect phone call this new
perfect phone call this new recording
apparently is going to show us that
Trump was pressuring the Speaker of the
House in Georgia so I mean there is a
possibility
but John Eastman definitely is at the
heart of the Jack Smith probe so now
rather John Eastman gets convicted in
these other states you know I get I
guess we'll find out
um what his participation was inside the
states I definitely think Rudy Giuliani
and Jenna Ellis are at high risk here in
those other states if the road map is
laid out with uh with Georgia but the
question is will those States take on
those indictments and spend that money
in those prosecutors spend the diamond
money to indict someone who is already
imprisoned in another state for the same
exact crime we'll see we'll see so a
good question there Mitchell
what else do we get
and what else do we got here one of the
questions on the in the chat
we're shooting the [__] here see if we
can get to
um
a few cons
uh Gabe Sanchez might um might uh join
us Audio Only
trying to work through his internet he's
got cell phone service but it's still
kind of shaky
um
so I'm trying to make sure that if he
comes in we can hear him at least okay
what else do we got here and maybe he
can tell us the story about where we
went to and what he was doing on
vacation his
um
his George Soros funded
antifa headquarters visitation it was I
think I think that's probably what he's
gonna tell us what do you think you
think that's where he was where do you
guys think he was I don't know you got
any guesses well let's see we got any
more questions here
trying to find some questions
oh boy this you guys
it's crazy how many people show up every
day to watch this show
it is crazy how how much you guys show
up for this show it's hard to even get
through this uh okay he wants me to oh
he I think he's gonna join us folks I
think uh Gabe Sanchez is going to join
us and let's see let me send him the
there it is
there we go uh okay he's he's trying to
he's trying to get into the uh the show
here on his cell phone let's see
um
will the house of reprehensibles ever be
accounted Jan ask will the house of rep
I I think you're I think you're talking
about the mongolianites in our uh
National legislator the House of
Representatives under Kevin coward
McCarthy I'm gonna show you a video
today speaking of the reprehensibles the
also represent reprehensible I'm going
to show you a video today and you guys
have probably already seen this Marjorie
Taylor green uh talking about a bag of
sand uh but she she totally [__] she
totally gives classified confidential
information right out in the open uh she
doesn't even know it until Ortiz
um the the witness that she's
questioning from border patrol lets her
know uh what she's doing in that moment
he's trying to hint to her and then
she's like I don't give a [__] so we're
gonna we're gonna I'm gonna show you how
she's giving away confidential
information and then after the fact
and I'm I'm guessing I'm guessing she's
gonna be on bonehead for this of course
we have bone end of the week tomorrow
and the poll will come out um this
afternoon
but speaking of the House of
representables
um now the problem Jan is that the House
of Representatives controls their Ethics
Committee
um and because the Republicans are very
unethical they don't want the Ethics
Committee to investigate themselves so
if we have accountability it'll probably
be after the country has spoken in 2024
and we give the house back
and make Hakeem Jefferies uh the speaker
of the house which by the way
that is a good way to hold these traders
in Congress account by making jet um
Akeem Jeffries the speaker of the house
I think King Jeffries
has the likelihood of being one of the
longest serving speaker of the house
um ever I really believe that I think
he's going to show that he is probably
up there with one of the most effective
speakers in the house and the one reason
why I I am in love with Hakeem Jeffries
being speaker of the house is because
the guy understands National messaging
and National narrative he understands
that that is the Forefront of the battle
that we are in
um it is just not policy and policy
making
um that we that where we need to battle
we need to battle with messaging and
Democrats have failed on that front for
a long time I think we have with us
um if you'll give me just a second we'll
stop the shoot the shift for just a
second I think we have with us uh on the
telephone Gabe Sanchez Gabe Sanchez can
you hear
yeah I can hear you oh my gosh there he
is everyone uh there's his pretty little
picture he's he's joining us by Audio
Only apparently uh George didn't pay
your your electric bill or something is
that what's going on over there yeah I
don't know what's going on I'm uh I feel
like it's the Russians attacking my
electricity over here uh
so so are you so are you back are you
back to Earth now I mean have you ever
been back home from yeah I'm I'm back uh
I met I met the aliens that uh that we
thought were the Chinese air balloons
um there was some probing some prodding
but we're friends now you know we're
very good friends now but uh yeah I'm
back
back on Earth uh where were you I was
surmising earlier that you may have
taken some sort of antifa retreat to an
undisclosed uh antifa headquarters
funded by George Soro somewhere but I
don't think that's exactly where you
were at what what were you doing on
vacation this past
I was uh I was visiting family in Mexico
oh you were in Mexico so where at in
Mexico did you go
uh so I went to uh Mexico City uh where
I got a family and then I've also got
family in cordovacca which is a it was a
another city in a different state of
Mexico that's like 45 or so minutes away
catch it well you know Mexico is in the
news and I was gonna I was I was really
looking forward to you
um commenting on the Marjorie Taylor
green uh situations she put herself in
she's obviously wants to go yeah well
she wants to go to war with the Mexican
cartel too
um that's a dumb that's a that's uh that
is a very dumb thing to do
let me ask you let me ask you because
you were let me ask you because you were
in Mexico and I you know I'm I'm
completely ignorant of the places where
you were I just don't know I've never
been there
um yeah yeah what do you let's just say
I was not in the places where the guitar
where where the cartel would kidnap you
um you know
like so what you're saying what you're
saying is is that the the idea that
Mexico the cartel controls the entire
thing is absolutely [__] is that
what you're saying yeah I mean well it's
not that they I mean I will say the
cartel does have a stronghold on a fair
amount of Max
okay
um
look at the politics of people in the
geopolitical landscape of it there are
people that are you know corrupt right
like politics is corrupt um
uh but there are there are aspects okay
the cartel is bad is dangerous that is
for sure do they control as much as
Republicans want to claim no do they
control a decent amount yes
uh do are they fear-mongering yes are
they trying to place blame on someone
else for their own problems in America
yes 100 percent
uh I would also say if that you're ever
going to go I mean the other thing too
is like the story of the kidnapping that
would like that was happening in real
time while I was there and we were
following it to be like this is such a
weird story how did this happen
um why is it uh why is it playing out
the way that it is I mean that whole
thing is just weird in and of itself
like that's the or even even the
aftermath even the aftermath where the
cartel pretty much handed over the
people who has mistaken these identities
and kidnapped and killed is kind of a
weird timeline
right and also keep in mind that you
know the if it's Mexicans at the cartel
are killing I mean there's a there's a
ton of people that are killed by women
every day in Mexico which is a very sad
thing to happen and it's very sad thing
to see
um but also the
um
the area they went to was not safe
that's not a place you would go to to
get like plastic surgery or something
it's very very sucks like it's it's all
right it's a cartel like run area and
then you know on top of that
the whole like giving them over
my like what I would assume is the
reason is because it's an international
incidence right you've got Americans
that came over and now are kidnapped and
it's like the whole reason why when uh
there were the Olympics in Brazil they
were like all right look cartel down
here and the police let's come to an
agreement that no one
no one gets hurt no one gets kidnapped
no one gets injured nothing happens
because we don't want an international
incident to happen uh and I think that's
kind of what happened with the cartel is
they
were they looked at the situation
they're like all right yeah these people
made an assumption they were certain
other people not who they really were uh
there was some confusion
um and that's why they handed them over
and and wrote the note that was like we
didn't we didn't agree to this we didn't
give them permission
so that's what I think
we have a listener uh in Mexico Fred
here says he's listening from Mexico uh
from Vegas yeah so
um but I have a couple questions here
we're in the shoot this [__] they're
answering some questions so oh wait hold
on wait yeah no I got the I got the
company coming they're calling me back
okay well we'll have to maybe maybe
you'll you'll be back on Gabe Sanchez
everyone yeah he joined us by phone
we'll see we'll see you soon my friend
all right see you yep all right and as
Gabe Sanchez tries to get his um his
problem fixed over there with his power
so he's joining us by phone through his
um internet connection
so there there you have Gabe Sanchez
let's see if we can get some more
questions and here we have a few minutes
uh before the top of the hour we'll go
to a break and when we come back we'll
go through the shitless Roundup we'll
I'm going to give you these um I'm gonna
give you these uh uh
these video highlights that we have
going uh let's see do you guys got any
more questions here now for me I had a
couple questions here for Gabe it was um
people wanted to know if he was
bilingual
and then if he visited a gun store in
Mexico City
um so maybe maybe we'll get those
questions out to him if he gets back on
the air maybe we'll ask him tomorrow uh
those questions
let's see do we have any more um do we
have any more questions here for shoot
the [__] and then we'll and then we'll
go do a break if you don't have any more
questions
oh here we go
uh
oh Tony will DeSantis accept me Ukraine
invite or puss out try common sense I
mean invite to what you think I mean
here's the thing again I keep telling
you this I keep telling you this I don't
think Ron DeSantis is going to run for
president I know he's teasing it I know
it feels like it I know people are
saying he's going to I know it makes
sense that he might I I want him to
don't get me wrong I want him to run and
the reason why I want him to run is I
want Donald Trump and him to destroy
each other that is what I want that is
what I think will be best going into
2024 is to let them let them fight it
out in a Republican primary because
remember
this is the season that we're in this is
the cycle that we're in we are in a
Republican primary cycle
okay and that is how you need to frame
up all your messaging it's important if
you keep that in mind first
that the election cycle that we are in
is in a Republican primary
and that is how you frame all your
messaging
all of it
against these fascists than having
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis in the
race together is good for that messaging
good to push that narrative it will be
they will serve it up on a [__]
platter trust me they're already doing
it now and he's not even currently in
the race but if Ron DeSantis makes the
choice not to get in the race which I
think he will do at some point he will
say no I'm not going to run for
president
um because there is a state law where he
has to not be Governor as well he's
trying to change it but there is a state
law
again I hope he gets in I hope he gets
in I really do but I don't think
anything Ron DeSantis does I don't think
anything pudding meatball does at this
point is going to make a hell of beans
worth the difference because Donald
Trump is going to attack him at every
turn uh for instance Banning books
Donald Trump is likely to attack him on
Banning books all the while Donald Trump
is going to call to ban books Donald
Trump can do this Ron DeSantis cannot
okay if you've ever if you don't know
that Donald Trump can can provide two
different answers to the same question
that are opposite and his cult will
follow him with a wink and a nod you
have not been paying attention Rhonda
santis is not the same way he does not
have that power over these people he
just doesn't we watched it live on air a
clip we showed several weeks ago when
Brian Kilmeade of Fox News was in
Florida in a diner and he couldn't get
anyone even a woman with a Rhonda Santa
shirt on to commit that they would vote
for DeSantis over Trump
I'm telling you I'm telling you
these indictments are going to
strengthen Trump and it's going to
strengthen the cult around him and it's
going to be by association why do you
think all these Republicans are saying
well I don't want Trump to be the
nominee but I'll vote for him wink
so will the scientists accept Ukraine
invite or puss out I I don't know that
Ron DeSantis it even matters
unless he gets in which I want him to
get in don't don't get
um my feelings about how I believe that
he won't get in of me not wanting him to
get in I definitely think it is
um
let's see uh Kenneth says um what was it
that became the turning point which made
you become the voice of the side side
feet left
I know what that means I'm not sure
exactly what you're asking here which
made which made you become the voice the
side for the left I think maybe is what
you're asking uh what do you mean I I
mean I'm a liberal I'm a proud liberal I
don't think liberal is a bad thing go
look up the word I say this all the time
go look up the word liberal
and try to tell me that you're not a
liberal I mean it's going to be very
difficult in this country to find a lot
of people you don't have to tell them
then it's the word liberal just read
someone the definition of the word
liberal and say does this describe you
does this describe you
damn well better bet that they're going
to be liberal so I'm a liberal
so the left wing in this country
is a bunch of liberals who believe in
democracy it's kind of weird though
on the left in this country because of
the pendulum swing of the right wing
went so far fascist that everyone
appears to be a liberal
um everyone appears to be a liberal
there's no such thing as conservative
anymore do you hear anyone hardly
anywhere using the word conservative
no you don't because there aren't
conservatives because even the the
classic conservatives who were thin
veiling the word conservatism to hide
the Republicans fascism and they're
playing footsie with fascism uh doesn't
even exist I mean you got like the
Lincoln project you got Republicans
against Trump
uh because they they bought in to their
own [__] over the years and and
decided oh we're concerned I'm a
conservative well I'm a conservative
well you were hiding your fascism by
Thin veiling it as conservatism
for a long time since the 19 late 70s
really and up until the early 80s and
and into the 80s when Ronald Reagan
became president and that was the birth
of the far right right-wing talk radio
so I mean
was what was the turning point for me I
was never a conservative I mean I grew
up in uh the white racist institution of
Rural America
but I mean I just grew up and used my
own eyes and my own ears to realize
facts and to realize that my liberalism
that I had even when I was a part of
that institution and raised in that
institution of rural white racism and
that's what it is that's the privilege
that I've got that I that I inherited
that I want to [__] kill in this
country and smash up with a goddamn
Hammer so that everyone has the same
privilege the same equity and the same
equality that I was born with because of
my [__] skin color my [__] gender
and where I'm from
so the turning point for me was I don't
know I grew up and had common [__]
sense and used my brain to establish
what facts are and how things work
and that's when I decided that I'd yell
and scream into the tick tock
and that's what gave this show what you
have today every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch don't forget to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
don't miss a single episode also follow
us on Twitter download every
[__] all the Band episodes too
did you know this that there are banned
episodes out there but they're all
downloadable you can download them Apple
Spotify Google
maybe I should make like a playlist
somewhere you think that's what I should
do make a playlist of all the banned
episodes so you can go listen to the
maybe you can find why they banned them
you can find why they banned them
they're not banned on the the
directories they're just being on
YouTube that's it well Facebook is
taking a couple of them down too I think
I don't think twitch has but twitch they
delete after a certain period of time
speaking of twitch
go follow us on Twitch and also link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account give us your one free
subscription and follow us on Facebook
well at the Tony Michaels don't go
anywhere we're gonna be right back I'm
gonna show you some video with this
shitless Roundup we're gonna round up
the Tweety tweets and trendy trends that
including that video of Marjorie hoof
foot Petty Yeti green
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out of Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again
years bomb
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
a come Buckle [__] a [__] em [__]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
ah you all remember the trucker Convoy
one of my favorite ears I know it's one
of your favorites you try to play it
every once in a while it's not really a
commercial but it's a break you know
what I mean it's a funny video [__] them
haha
now welcome back to the show you guys
had fun on the shoot the [__] if you
want to do more type of shoot the [__]
I'll tell you what you need to do is go
to the tonymichaels.com check out our
patreon page I believe tomorrow I'm
gonna schedule it I'll let you know I'll
post it on patreon and then I'll
probably post it on Twitter and Facebook
too uh if you want to come and check out
what patreon is but we're gonna do an
ask me anything where it's similar to
the shoot the [__] but it's a little
more private and fewer people and I'll
answer any question that you have there
absolutely any question I don't care
what it is
um about politics or personal I try to
keep the questions here on the show
during the um shoot the [__] more
politics but
um on ask me anything you literally can
ask me anything so go to the Tony
michaels.com check out the patreon page
or go to patreon.com Michaels will do
ask me anything tomorrow afternoon after
the show I haven't decided what time yet
but I'll I'll schedule it I have a few
other meetings I think uh tomorrow
afternoon so I gotta see when those are
scheduled but it'll be about 30 minutes
long so go check out patreon at
patreon.commichaels or go to the Tony
michaels.com and click the patreon link
we have some new members here in the
last few days so thank you for all the
support over on patreon for all those
members I'm going to give you shout outs
sometime next week
um to all the new members that and
earned and shout outs
hey boy Marjorie Taylor green
what a [__] idiot I know she's gonna
end up on boned there's no question no
way she doesn't end up on bonehead right
she's undefeated absolutely undefeated
in this Arena of bonehead
um we have another bonehead this morning
too uh Marcia Blackburn I'm going to
show you how Marsha Blackburn oh my God
guess what's gonna happen these woke
lefties oh my God they're gonna they're
gonna take away your washing machines
I'm not [__] you I'm not it's not
gonna end it it's not gonna end with
these people they're gonna keep thinking
people are going to take away their
appliances I'm gonna tell you why now
they keep saying this stupid [__] I also
have a clip of James Comer I want to
show you uh where he's spreading more
Hunter by dick pic lines James Comer
James Comer is the guy he did you know
that [__] is the chair of the
oversight committee our oversight
committee it's our government
our government this bonehead who thinks
svb closed because of wokism now now is
spreading the same old conspiracy Leary
is conspiracy theory [__] about
Hunter Biden and his dick mix and the
laptop so we're gonna we're going to get
that I'm gonna get I want to show you
this uh pudding meatball story of Ronnie
tiny D desantos I'm going to show you
that as well and let's see what else do
we have
um on the plate oh yes oh yes the sand
ball the Marjorie Tater green I also
have a state rep in Wisconsin uh Donna
rosar that I want to show you this pile
of [__] we're gonna go after her a
little bit because she's trying to Tamp
down women's rights even if you've been
raped she thinks she thinks if women are
raped little little girls little girl
teenage girls that are raped it's a good
thing and God wants them to carry that
rapist baby to full term and she's gonna
tell us her stupid [__] reasoning
behind it also I want to see if I can um
talk to you about the uh child labor
laws that are being stripped in Arkansas
this is [__] crazy and they're in uh
Piper of Missouri Piper is a brilliant
brilliant brilliant mind and I've been
trying to get her on the show and I
think I miss a message from her and I'd
like to have her on the show to talk
more about this but she did a video on
this this morning where she's talking
about how uh School vouchers is actually
a they're trying to March towards more
child labor and getting uh these child
labor laws rescinded that's what they
mean by make America great again they
want poor folks and people of color to
send their children for labor so that
rich white folks get to keep their
privilege I'm not [__] you I'm going
to show you why I also want to show you
speaking of of schools and children Ben
Shapiro
[__] Nazi yeah that's right that
[__] Nazi Ben Shapiro at the daily
wire that Nazi rag the daily wire
um he he says children are stupid okay
children are stupid and we got a lot of
video to get to here today so bear with
me I'm gonna go pretty fast children are
stupid and and feeding children in
school will not fix their hunger
he just doesn't know what hunger is and
how it works so where shall we start
let's start with Marjorie Taylor green
here uh so let's let's get to the
shitless Roundup and let's uh get to
Marjorie Taylor green and how she's
giving out confidential information in a
public hearing
let's start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
welcome welcome back to the show to the
[__] list Roundup we ran up all the
Tweety tweets of trendy Trends I'm gonna
go pretty fast because we get a lot of
video to get here to today uh here is uh
Marjorie hoodfoot green the likely
bonehead of the week
I'm just I mean what am I supposed to do
she's a big [__] bonehead every week
we have to put her on the pole because
she
is a huge bonehead and she's undefeated
literally undefeated
and the bone end of the weak Bowl but
here she is doing a bone-headed thing
where she's giving confidential
information in a public hearing about
the location where they are surveilling
Mexican cartel listen to how
um
someone has to explain this the witness
that she's questioning Hanks to explain
this to her in real time let's listen
you're sick and tired of our young
people dying our our emergency
responders getting poisoned by fentanyl
this this is unacceptable Chief Ortiz
are you aware that there was an
explosive device found by border patrol
agents on January 17th in an area called
No Man's Land okay so she's saying
there's an explosive device and found by
this border patrol that we're
surveilling and she gives away the
location No Man's Land she gives away
the location where they're surveilling
so listen to how he responds here and
there's surveillance of who did it there
and guess what it wasn't Americans it
was cartels are you aware of that now
listen to his response here he's gonna
try to tell her hey dummy stop saying
that stupid [__] listen
thank you congresswoman and good to see
you again I will tell you that uh some
of this information that I receive I
receive in a a confidential uh skiff so
I'm going to be a little hesitant of
briefing what I
know and what I don't know with respect
to some of those an event like that
what he's talking about is he is not he
does not want to give away to the cartel
in an open hearing confidently
confidential information where he knows
that border border patrol is surveilling
those areas to keep them I don't know
what do you call it safe and secure
this [__] idiot this ignorant [__]
moglodyte Marjorie Taylor green has just
given away information to the cartel
unknowingly now I've been telling you
this time and time and time and time
again and I'm going to be repeating it
from now until November 2020 for 2024
and probably after
the reason why Marjorie Taylor green
does stupid [__] [__] like this not
only because she's a dumb [__]
but the reason why is because she has no
serious people working for her because
no one's serious enough in Washington to
want a career there after these
moglodytes lose and leave
it's gonna want to work for this [__]
fool what happens when you a
congressperson is only as good as their
staff
if you have ignorant stupid morons as
your staff you're going to end up doing
stupid [__] moronic things like she
just did right out in the open which is
give cartel confident confidential
information of where border secure
border patrol is securing the Border by
surveilling them they now know because
of this [__] buffoon
where they are being surveilled in this
area
now they have the ability not to do
certain things in that area you [__]
idiot watch what she says after he tells
her he says here hey dummy this is
confidential information that I was
given in a skiff I'm sure you were too
because of the classification of it why
are you saying it out loud you [__]
idiot
listen to her response
I understand Chief Ortiz but I'm not
going to be confidential because I think
people deserve to know okay again again
again again again she knows she stepped
in it but she doesn't go oh whoops I'm
[__] sorry she doubles down on it now
I can continue to play this stupid thing
but the point is is that they found a
bag of sand that is the thing she's
concerned about she they found a bag of
sand they thought maybe initially that
it was an exclusive advice it was not
it was not and this morning she's
tweeting about it and I could show you
but I'm not even gonna get to that it's
just not enough time but this morning
she was tweeting about that oh that bag
of sand and explosive and blah blah blah
yakety smackity the thing that you gave
away that was confidential you [__]
idiot is the location where Border
Patrol was surveilling what you the
enemy that you want to go to war with
because that's the other thing this
morning on Steve bannon's show she's
calling to go to war with the Mexican
cartel this is really stupid you don't
go to war with the Mexican cartel you
dummy
oh my God it just the stupidity is
unbounding
and I just I can't even [__] tell you
how un on
um how I'm frustrating
it truly is to have these [__]
boneheads be in our government it's it's
dumbfounding speaking of idiots here's
uh here's the um leader of the Nazi rag
over at Daily wire who is leading their
Scourge against uh lgbtq people in this
country uh calling for their eradication
so much so that um their little uh their
support group dressed up as Nazis
they're Nazis and went and uh protest a
drag show in Wadsworth Ohio their daily
their daily wire
um listeners apparently and daily wire
supporters they showed up to support
their Theory and to protest people
dressing up in costumes uh and
Performing uh so here here is but here's
Ben Shapiro talking about how kids are
stupid and we shouldn't listen to kids
you know what actually [__] this I'm not
gonna show that I'm not gonna show that
clip I don't have enough time and I want
to show you another clip of this [__]
idiot this is even better
um now you you guys have seen that we um
have shown Ben Shapiro doing the gun
show you remember this
so he does these stupid [__]
um he does these q and A's right now he
does them it looks like from his cell
phone right now this is probably some
kind of exclusive access to some to some
uh membership somewhere on the daily
wire just like I do ask me anything
right you have access to me you can ask
me anything it's kind of the same thing
but they ask him to do the gun show now
what I'm saying is here's here's what
I'm saying
is that please
please do I I you can come join patreon
and and and and participate there and do
the ask me anything but please
please do not ask me to do this gun show
thing this is so stupid where he flexes
and he did Grunts and [__] please do not
do that someone will screen capture and
put it all over the Internet do not do
that now in this
in this um I know you [__] you
[__] are tricky out there you
my audience is smart my audience is
smart I know they are I know they would
do this uh she she look at the mighty
Librarians let's see the guns
boy
um maybe maybe in patreon maybe
um please don't do that please don't do
that
uh yeah I I get what you're doing now uh
so here is here's Ben Shapiro now he's
not going to do the gun show here he's
not going to do the gun show here I
promise I'm not going to show you that
video I wouldn't turn
um that the entire audience away and and
kicked him off the broadcast here by
showing this guy giving his guns but he
is going to answer a question here now
this is hilarious the reason why this is
hilarious is you got to remember this is
one of his supporters asking him this
question
so listen to the question that he reads
first I'm gonna stop it and I'm gonna
tell you why that's hilarious let's
listen
if Government can protect kids from the
sick radical election they also put
their kids from Hunger
Okay so
uh I don't I really don't know if this
is a troll or if it's a supporter it's
supposed to be the supporter but
oh man that's hilarious the question is
if the sick radical left if we can if
the government can protect us from the
sick radical left can it protect kids
from Hunger now it feels like a troll to
me but he takes the bait he takes the
[__] bait watch would it make sense
to strengthen food stamps and have
school lunch be free since some kids are
in school lunch debt okay so the The
Following part of the question was is
about school lunch in other words so the
idea is is this and we did this during
the pandemic and it's it's really a
shame
um that the build back better bill I
call it the Big Bird Bill didn't have
better messaging and better narrative
behind it
as an education bill because I believe
that if Democrats would have framed up
the bill back better bill as an
education Bill starting school at three
instead of five so parents didn't have
to pay for daycare providing school
lunch to all children no matter what
their income no matter who they were
we're just gonna [__] feed kids
because that's what we should be doing
in this country Jesus Christ we got
enough money in this country to feed
kids we should be doing it uh to to stop
childhood hunger it's just what we
should be doing by feeding them
um we would be in an entirely different
situation and the reason why this these
subjects come up is because Democrats
actually did that for a period of time
we did feed all children at school lunch
everywhere
um it didn't matter what your income if
you were in public schools you got a
[__] meal and that's the way that's
the way it should be the meal should be
per part of the education I don't give a
[__] who you are I don't care what your
income your parents income that child
goes to that public school we in this
country should say we should give them
nutrition so they can learn we shouldn't
charge them
for the [__] nutrition so they can
learn it's really kind of backwards
thinking but listen to what Ben Shapiro
says here
about school lunches
children eating school lunches and how
it doesn't make them hungry anymore I
don't know listen uh well I mean if you
are a parent school lunches are not
going to solve the problem of child
hunger at any serious level
okay people think this [__] [__] is
smart
okay there are people running around
this country thinking that this [__]
idiot is smart when he says when he says
that school lunches
are not going to help solve child hunger
what the [__] is gonna help solve child
hunger other than meals you [__]
idiot
how in the [__] listen Okay during the
pandemic if you remember this during the
pandemic
um government heads had to put put their
brains together to figure out how they
were going to feed children
um during while the schools were closing
a lot of them were doing um uh
homeschooling
and during the summer during the the
pandemic they had to put their heads
together and here's what they discovered
Ben Shapiro and here's the facts you
[__] idiot there is one piece of
infrastructure in this country that we
have built over the last century okay we
have built this infrastructure over the
last century to have kitchens and
cafeterias that are designed
and intended
to feed all the children in the country
okay we have infrastructure that is
built
to feed all children everywhere in the
country
wherever there is a public school there
is a building with a [__] kitchen
a [__] cafeteria in it we have built
that infrastructure with our tax dollars
that's what we the people have done as
the government to make sure that
children eat and get nutrition you
[__] idiot now
what you have not realized you haven't
used your [__] brain power you
haven't gone you have you need to spend
a little more time thinking about you
know good ideas as opposed to focusing
on people's genitalia and what people
are doing with their genitalia maybe if
you just took a little time outside of
that and thought about facts and [__]
that's real like the infrastructure that
is built to feed children
we have it it exists
we use it every mother [__] day to
feed Millions tens of millions of
children all across the country
that we as we as a society could decide
to use that infrastructure more
efficiently to make sure that all
children every [__] one of them get
three meals not one not two but three
meals a [__] day seven days a [__]
week we can do it it is a possibility
all we have to do is I don't know have
some empathy and compassion and I don't
know you saved the children [__] could
actually get off your ass instead of
protesting in front of an abortion
clinic and protesting Women's Health
Care get your ass to the [__] state
house and make sure that children
protest so children can [__] eat and
it not cost them a God damn dime we can
do that in this country it's our money
it's our government it's our
infrastructure we have the possibility
of doing this part of the build back
better Bill the one that should have
been been [__]
should have been
message as an education bill
would have done that to some degree not
far enough not as far as I want to go I
mean to be honest with you I believe
that that school cafeteria should be
opened up everywhere they should be
opened up a lot longer than they are
just with the school hours our
government and we should fund those
cafeterias and those kitchens to stay
open seven days a [__] week and be
available not just for children but also
their families to go get nutrition it is
[__] ridiculous that we have this
infrastructure in this country and we
cannot use it all we have to do is
provide the resources to make sure that
people do not go hungry we have the
capability we have the infrastructure in
every [__] community
this is important listen listen to his
justification here though it gets even
worse
if there is a problem with children
naturally starving that is a child
endangerment scenario in which CPS needs
to be called uh if you're talking about
actual child starvation the truth is it
does not take that much money to feed a
child I know I have three of them uh the
he has three kids wait a second whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait a second
he has three children
how the hell did he with his wife not
being able okay well I'm not gonna go
there I ain't gonna have time
we've seen your child before you feed
yourself
it's that simple oh Jesus Christ much
deeper problem at work than school
lunches oh my God
what a [__] idiot what a [__]
idiot there are people out there that
think this guy is smart
they think this guy is smart he can't
think past well you should call CPS
Child Protective Service the government
to make sure that they feed children so
he's like oh well we shouldn't we
shouldn't be spending tax dollars to
feed children what we should do is spend
tax dollars for the government to take
away children from parents who can't
afford their food and custody and spend
all kinds of money and then to make this
is those stupid [__] stupid
what a [__] bonehead I can it is
befuddling to me how any of his [__]
supporters his samps don't know that
he's a dumb [__] Okay I gotta
move on here
um So speaking of childhood education I
want to move to uh Piper of Missouri uh
it is she did a great video on uh
um
education education and child labor and
what they're looking to do I said quote
make America great again this is what
they're talking about this is what they
want to do uh to poor folk all around
the country and this is what they're
doing with the voucher system listen to
this video by Piper uh maybe it'll
explain a little better of what she's
trying to do and also what's happening
in Arkansas uh here's Piper here let me
get it going there you go attacking
Public Schools privatizing them with
vouchers is completely related to
Rolling back child labor laws in
Missouri 30 percent of schools are on a
four-day school week I worked in one the
high schoolers on that fifth day usually
go to work they're working at Casey's
McDonald's or they're babysitting other
kids who aren't in school that day and
it's happening in state after State you
know that Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
attacking public schools in Arkansas now
look at this Arkansas Bill to remove
work permit requirement for children
under 16 goes to Sanders desk they have
the audacity to call this the youth
hiring act would delete the portion of
the existing law that requires an
employment certificate accessible to the
division of labor and the division of
Elementary and secondary education
before a company can hire a child under
16 years of age state law currently
prohibits children under 16 from working
more than eight hours a day opponents of
this bill have expressed concerns that
will open the door to violations of
child labor requirements and put
children at risk of human trafficking
Iowa is also passing a school voucher
scheme
look at this a new bill rolling back
child labor laws in Iowa to allow 14
year olds to work hazardous jobs in the
mining meat packing and logging sectors
this is related you don't have to put on
a tinfoil hat to see what's going on
they are trying to get rid of public
schools by privatizing them eventually
we'll go back to the feudal system where
everyone has to pay to get their kid in
education even K through 12 and those
kids whose parents can't pay for them to
go to school what are they going to do
they're going to go to work
it's not a conspiracy theory when they
lay it out for you to see it's right
there please pay attention please share
this please tell people what they are
doing they don't want to educate our
kids they want our kids to work for
theirs that's it that's it
and Piper's right here in a nutshell
what they're trying to do is roll back
schooling to where schooling is not
mandatory that way kids don't have to go
to school they have to work especially
the ones that I don't know can't afford
to go to school hmm
hell boy she's spot on and this is what
I'm and again I know this sounds weird I
know it sounds weird and again you don't
have to put on a 10 volt hat to realize
this they're using marginalized groups
like transgender children to roll back
parents consent
that way they have even a better
opportunity to do this what they're
doing and again this in quotes is make
America great again this is where they
want to go back to
they don't only want to keep their white
privilege they want they want to make
sure to elevate their white privilege
this is all white supremacy folks every
[__] last bit of it every [__]
last bit of it um one more point on
education a video I found uh
Marjorie Gaylor Queen
had posted this video from Tick Tock um
this is really quick
um so I want to show this as well this
is a conversation that an educator was
Hamming with someone on Tick Tock
literally they were having a
conversation with someone on Tick Tock
about this in like a live listen to what
this [__] idiot says and listen to
how she's trying to explain to him
um what education is and why you teach
children education and why they need to
have the knowledge that they need to
understand situations that they may not
understand unless we educate them listen
so should first graders be taught
success when it comes to comprehensive
sex education if we're looking at grades
K through four we're looking at first
grades we're looking at first grade so
it essentially would be family circles
that there are different family Dynamics
some families
anatomical names of body parts what is
unsafe and what is safe touch yeah
boy need to know what the Volvo is it's
not Volvo
look the reason why we need to teach
first graders like uh actual names of
body parts is because you think a Volva
is a Volvo obviously just in just in the
first few seconds of talking to this
[__] idiot
is is more justification of why you need
to educate people this guy has no
[__] clue no clue that there is a
difference between a Volvo and a Volva
now he is a man he's a [__] idiot
most men aren't [__] idiots okay
they're idiots they're just boneheads
even if you tell them this stuff like
the difference between a Volvo which is
an automobile and a Volvo which is a
woman's body part they still are not
going to retain the difference okay
they're just not and the reason why is
because again men are [__] selfish
idiots and as long as it doesn't have to
do with them what do they give a [__]
I'm telling you I is one this is
generally how the male brain works I
know it might be sexist and I might be a
a gender Trader but men are [__] dumb
they're just we're [__] stupid
and it's ridiculous I I I you want proof
here here's more proof listen although
Volvo is a brother witnesses that his
sister's vulda is touched in an unsafe
manner he should be able to know is
private parts don't touch it
you know it wouldn't be a sister
touching a little boy a boy I gave you
an example to where that information
would be helpful it would not be helpful
yeah again she's in the conversation
with him she's in the conversation with
him and he still does not know the
difference between
hell more evidence and you know he he's
obviously an idiot because at the end of
this video and I'm not going to show it
because I really don't have enough time
here he asked if she's vaccinated and
she face Palms right because it's just
[__] ridiculous but you have to go
watch this entire video and please share
it uh it's on my timeline if you're on
Twitter uh Jesus Christ you gotta watch
this I mean he's a [__] [__] it's
ridiculous but this is this is just what
we have to deal with uh in this country
right now okay let's see
oh oh here's another one here's another
one here's another one uh our friend
Walter Masterson has a mom's a liberty
here's another uh [__] fascist group
that is trying to take away education in
this country and and really again this
is not only a March towards taking away
parental consent
but what they're attacking also is uh
teachers and they're also attacking
mothers in this country that's why they
call it moms for Liberty like that's the
idea is we're we're against moms having
Liberty right like that again when they
call something a thing they're doing the
opposite of that like
um all this idea of parental rights and
education they're doing the opposite
they're trying to take away parental
rights and parental consent in education
it's always projection it's always them
doing the opposite thing of what they
say they're doing but Walter matters in
here this is hilarious
um as Walter is but he's questioning one
of the ahead of moms of Liberty which
again it's the opposite it's her trying
to take away mother's Liberty of their
children's choice but listen so you're
with moms for Liberty so you're telling
me there's a new threat besides gender
ideology besides critical race Theory
what's this third one
so social emotional learning social
emotional learning is the threat to our
country listen to what she says it is
when you're teaching students social
emotional learning if they learn a
certain word and a certain uh thing that
you could have as a human being how it's
wrong is basically the Trojan Horse that
allows critical race theory that allows
a critical queer Theory teaching our
kids how to feel teaching our kids how
to feel oh my God imagine imagine
oh man what an enemy teaching our kids
how to feel I wonder what feelings they
should teach them how to feel
they talk about their feelings they talk
about their feelings
it's called formative
big words
how could we show empathy oh my God can
you imagine can you imagine teaching
children in this country how to show
empathy oh Jesus can you imagine if we
actually have human beings in this
country with empathy do you can you even
fathom
the absolute chaos
that we would have if we taught children
empathy Jesus [__] Christ are you
serious this is the person who is
supposedly
for the liberty of moms well you know
that's the name of the organization it's
doing the opposite that's it let's
listen
let's say that we have the teaching so
empathy Okay so
it's important
if you have a friend that has two moms
how can you have empathy well my child
comes home and says mom there can be two
moms
uh thank you Walter for doing the work
that we all need you to do which is
hell trying to have conversations with
these [__] boneheads but again I'm
telling you this fight this fight for
um your consent and your rights is
happening right in your doorstep of your
Children's Schools
and with your consent why do you think
why do you think they TR they try to
they try to couple the two things
together drag queens and Story Hour
Story Hour education teaching children
how to read
drag queens drag queens are trans people
which is not true again they're trying
to get the culture wars started where
they want it to happen is your children
they're not out to save the children
they're out to take them away they want
to traffic them is what they want to do
they're [__] [__] okay just like
the [__]
that I'm about to show you
um and I'm gonna skip around your
education and then we're gonna go to the
um the federal judge in Texas that's
trying to strip away rights for women to
have health care everywhere
um this person would love to do that too
it's bonehead Marsha Blackburn listen to
what she says the enemy is uh we just
heard moms of Liberty said empathy
teaching kids empathy is definitely the
enemy of our country but listen to what
Martian Blackburn says the left radical
left lunatics are gonna do okay I think
if you like your washing machine you
should be able to keep your washing
machine and now we're hearing the Biden
Administration they are wanting to make
washing machines less efficient use a
different detergent that's new gonna
cost you more in your clothes they won't
be as clean what what
did she just say did she say that that
Joe Biden is gonna gonna come take your
washing machine what the [__] is wrong
with these people okay
do you remember
do you remember a woman named Michelle
Bachmann do you remember this this this
is the pre-marsha Blackburn
Michelle Bachmann was one of the dumbest
members of Congress to ever take a seat
in Congress until uh people like Marsha
Blackburn uh Marjorie tether green
Lauren bobert showed up
long before that Michelle Bachmann used
to stand on stage and she used to talk
about how you're not going to take our
light bulbs away from us you can't force
us to have LED light bulbs you remember
this [__] do you remember this
okay so here is what is happening
here's what's happening
electricity is really [__] expensive
it's [__] expensive electricity I
don't know if you know this have you got
electric bill lately do you pay your
electric bill
it's really [__] expensive
okay
now
here's the problem
is that the majority
of electricity that that is used in the
household is used in appliances okay so
what the government does is it makes
sure that what manufacturers are doing
in this country just like the LED light
bulb versus the Inc the 200 year old
incandescent light bulb
that they're providing a way for
manufacturers to make sure that they are
producing products that are not going to
inadvertently use more electricity than
they need to use which is
drawing up the cost of [__]
electricity for average Americans
so what the government is doing our
government under our direction is doing
is to make sure
that they are telling manufacturers if
you had the technology to produce
washing machines refrigerators stoves
microwaves whatever the appliances
to be more efficient if you have the
technology to do that which they do
you will read tool to do that
and if you don't want to retool we will
make you retool to use that technology
because that's that is what the the
manufacturers don't want to do
they don't want to invest the capital to
retool their factories
to produce products that are more
efficient
and what she's talking about here as if
a [__] washing machine isn't going to
wash your clothes listen there's a lot
of different washing machines out there
and there's washing machines with
current technology that [__] suck and
there's some of them that are great
it's a thing it's a thing that happens
it is a thing
but what the government us under our
direction is saying is look to lower
electricity costs and electricity
consumption you as Appliance
manufacturers have to retool to make
these appliances more efficient if you
ever went into to buy an appliance and
has a big yellow tag on it the
efficiency tag that's because of us
because of the government because we
elected people who are smart and make
sure that we keep electric costs low in
this country so we're not inadvertently
consuming more electricity than we have
to because we're not keeping track of
Manufacturers and the technology that
they have to make them more efficient
it's [__] stupid [__] it's stupid
[__] it really is stupid ass [__] but it
shouldn't be surprising coming from this
stupid stupid ass
moglodyte
all right
there's my Marshall Blackburn and
speaking of another member she's a
senator now which is wild it's wild that
is that is wild that Marshall Blackburn
is United States Senator
it's [__] crazy
but here's a bonehead that is a um not
only is the United States House
Representative he's a congressman he is
the he's the chairman
of the oversight Committee of government
oh my god listen to what he says here
about Hunter Biden here we go and
there's very little support in my
congressional district uh for sending
Ukraine a blank check and I'll tell you
this the whole Barista thing stinks to
high heaven and you it's ironic that
that's what Jamie raskins my counterpart
on the oversight committee led the
impeachment of Donald Trump for a
supposed quid pro quo with Ukraine when
uh everything that that I'm researching
shows the quid pro quo was Joe Biden
holding up the foreign aid to Ukraine
during the Obama Administration in
exchange for the termination of that
special prosecutor who was investigating
corruption within barisma the company
that the then Vice President Biden's son
sat on the border so you know there's
nothing good here with the money ah
Jesus more laptop talk
from these idiots okay this has been
debunked for a long time it's the exact
opposite of what James Comer the
chairman of the house oversight
committee
who is privy to the information that we
are privy to and more information that
we are not privy to
but he's a liar
he's a [__] liar just like over the
weekend he was lying about svb it went
oh my God it went broke because it was
woke which is the exact opposite I mean
if you're considering Peter Theo woke
you're a dumb [__] but whatever
but James Comer here is absolutely
pulling out an old conspiracy theory
that has been done been debunked time
and time again
the barisma thing that he's talking
about Joe Biden is the vice president
when he was the vice president not when
he ran for president not when he was
decided he wasn't going to run for
president 2016 because his son Beau
Biden had passed away
um and he decided not to get in that
race but he got in the race joining long
before all that
what James Comer is alleging is that Joe
Biden was trying to get the prosecutor
not
to investigate barisma who Hunter Biden
sat on the board of Brisbane which is
the opposite of the truth
that is the opposite of the truth the
federal government and Joe Biden as
liaison was making sure
that the prosecutor was investigating
brisma or they wanted him out it's
really [__] stupid [__] it's easy to
look up you know it it's facts the crazy
part is there was reports at the time on
the issue before Trump even came into
the picture before Hunter Biden even
came into the picture there were reports
of what was happening with that issue
with barisma with the prosecutor
in real time there's reports you can go
back and look at it but James Comer does
not want to do that instead he wants to
spread [__] lies on Fox News and I'm
telling you you're gonna hear barisma
Prisma brisma Prisma here really [__]
soon it's gonna happen Okay um I gotta
go to this story I don't have video for
this this is a story uh uh Jake has here
it says um a feedback loop has a gun
forming around the Santas
in an early primary State campaign
venues trying to cater to his uh adverse
to the press and unpredictable
interactions with the public
but they still don't know exactly what
he wants okay we saw this in a video the
other day where
um Rhonda Santos was trying to have his
people not let reporters in because he
doesn't want reporters asking him
certain questions he doesn't want to
have to answer questions that he's
uncomfortable with that's why he won't
win that's why he won't get in okay he's
a [__] [__] but I'm gonna call him
pudding meatball putting meatball on
from now on
because there's a pudding incident in
this story I'm not [__] you it's a
pudding instrument the pudding incident
they're calling it the pudding incident
oh my God okay the pudding incident
which former the Santa staffers
described common instance of him not
reading the room okay
so here's what it is here's what it is
in 2000 uh
2019 a flight to DC
where he was eating pudding on a plane
in a private cabin
he was eating pudding with his [__]
three fingers now I'm assuming it's like
a snack pack right or maybe it's in a
bowl but this guy was eating pudding off
his [__] fingers
are you following that
I'm I'm again
new ex DeSantis staffers and those
involved in planning his book tour
pre-campaign events described
long-standing issues over his soft
skills coming to the four
as he hits the road example a 2019
flight to DC where he was eating pudding
with his fingers
[Laughter]
not for Trump to make fun a Rhonda
Santos for now listen I know we're gonna
mock around for this we're gonna mock
pudding meatball for this from now until
Kingdom Come
but don't you see how this is great I
again
I hate to say it like this but I am in
support and encouragement of trump
absolutely attacking Ron DeSantis Donald
Trump will destroy putting meatball he's
going to destroy put meatball's career
again do you remember a guy named Scott
Walker do you remember him
do you remember him oh my God
callahela here on YouTube says
spoons are woke oh
the war on wookism continues with uh
putting meatball Ronnie tiny D holy [__]
you can't make this [__] up but do you
remember the guy named Scott Walker he
was a governor he was going to be the
president he was going to be the
greatest [__] president of all time
he was he was supposed to be the candid
remember he was Paul Ryan's boy and he
[__] folded like a cheap lawn chair
in Iowa guess what Ron DeSantis did in
Iowa he folded up like a [__]
umbrella
yep Ronnie D is done he's done
he is [__] done I bet Nikki Haley has
a better chance of winning the
nomination
the mighty librarian points out a good a
good fact here and Scott Walker is a
creep he is a republican I mean
come on mining librarian you got you got
resources there you're supposed to be
our resource Queen
she's a republican so I mean obviously
but yes he was more creepy than some
Rhonda Santos is the same way he has
that same Swagger or non-swagger as you
want to call it
he just doesn't have it he's not ready
he won't be president he won't be the
nominee he's not going to get in the
race folks I doubt he gives up his
throne as the Florida fascist to get his
ass slaughtered
by the Cheeto dust q and honor Donald
Trump okay
I got um let's see I got another story I
want to get to here
um
for the Texas thing I talked about in
the first uh the front of the show but
here is a the recount had this video
here uh of Wisconsin state senator Donna
rosar now again these [__]
Republicans they're gonna do anything
and everything they can to take away
women's rights and this um this case in
in Texas is is uh panning out in their
favor here to strip away
a drug that would take away 50 percent
of abortion Services away from women in
this country
foreign
but here is uh Republican Donna rosar
listen to what she says
about rape and the rape exception or
the lack of the rape exception and and
how she wants little
teenage girls
who are raped
to carry their pregnancy to term listen
because I personally believe in life
from conception to Natural death it is
important that we tell women who are
victims of rape and incest to support
them if they choose to carry those
pregnancies to term
now she's not listening to her own
[__] words and it doesn't make much
sense to me I had to listen to this a
couple times did you hear what she just
says we support them in their choice
choice to carry at the term
then she follows it up with how she
doesn't want to give women the choice I
have had friends and family members who
have been a victim of rape not of incest
but of rape
oh not not of it
oh I mean they're rapist
did you catch that did you catch that
what the [__]
well listen what she says keep going and
that pregnancy was carried to turn there
was support there that baby was
relinquished for adoption and I'm sure
blessed the family in another state that
the baby was adopted into hey Donna
hey Donna
that woman
whoever she was that you're one woman
friend right this is the eye someone
said in the chat I have a black friend
this is I have a friend who's a woman
who who was raped and carried her baby
to term okay yeah but Donna what you're
saying is
what you're saying and I think you're
running into the point here is that if a
woman makes that choice
I think the pro-choice movement is for
her having the Liberty to make that
choice
think I think I think that's what we're
saying you're trying to say it as
enforcing people to have birth forcing
birth
but you're saying choice and you're
saying that was her choice and she made
a great choice and we're saying we want
them to choose
maybe a woman has a traumatic event of
rape or incest and she chooses
to carry that baby's germ what makes you
think we don't want that woman to have
the access and the health care to make
that choice because that's what we want
we want them to have the choice also the
choice not to carry at the term but
listen to what she says at the end here
so I know there can be positive outcomes
in rape situations where babies are
carried to terms and then relinquished
for adoption we need to make sure that
those supports are there for those women
and I am part of some support groups
that do
oh man oh man they run straight into the
into it don't they just bam right into
it right into it right into it
so this is why I want to force birth
because I believe I believe that life
begins at conception and I believe women
should have a choice even though I'm
saying they shouldn't have Choice I'm
saying that we should force them to
carry it to turn you aren't a dumb
[__] Donna rosar and again you
think you think Walgreens is the problem
right I've heard it from liberals ah
boycott Walgreens they're the evil
[__] doers this [__] here Donna
rosar who wants women to carry [__]
rapist babies to term
because herb [__] beliefs which we
don't give a [__] what you believe Donna
we don't give a [__] what you believe
your beliefs are not opinions
I don't know how many times I have to
say this beliefs are not opinions
opinions are based in fact
not in [__] fiction
this right here Donna rosar in Wisconsin
is the enemy of Liberty she wants to
strip away your rights to choice and
Liberty of your health care
this she is not she is not uh the CEO of
Walgreens
she is not
she is not on the board of Walgreens
she's not a store manager at Walgreens
pluck your head out of your [__] ass
and realize who the enemy of Liberty is
it's not Walgreens it's not
which leads me
to today ending with the story and I
don't have a [__] video for it I
apologize I'm sure there's plenty of
them out there
the story in Texas
where
a federal judge is going to strip away
the rights of women to consult with
their doctors to receive Health Care
and accounts for 50 percent of abortion
services in this country now
when you say abortion Services it means
Health Care you [__] mogulanites out
there still have not figured this out
it means Health Care
abortion Services
aren't you cutting up babies isn't
destroying life
it is Women's Health Care you
[__]
and the reason why Walgreens is doing
what they're doing and will continue to
do what they're doing is because of
Republicans
we sat back and watched Donald Trump get
elected in 2016. because we weren't
willing to engage and fight for our
democracy because we didn't see the
threat
we didn't see it it was a true threat we
now know what the threat is that these
fascists would put fascist [__]
judges on our courts our courts
to take away our [__] rights
I'm telling you
women's rights are humans rights and if
they go after women's rights or lgbtq
rights or people of colors rights
they're coming after yours they're not
gonna stop
Jesus Christ they overturned Roe v Wade
we heard for decades oh that's the one
thing we need to do we have to overturn
Roe v Wade that's all we have to do
that'll solve all the country's problems
is to overturn Roe v Wade they overturn
Roe v Wade and they're still at it
what they meant is their plan was to
start taking away women's rights by
overturning Roe v Wade and they won't
stop there
now this Federal judge's decision is
likely going to strip away the rights to
women to get health care and make their
health care decisions between them and
their [__] doctors
with this with this prescription
medication that is abortion services
and it accounts it accounts for almost
50 percent of abortion services in this
country not cutting up babies chopping
them up and eating a baby sandwich you
[__] mogulate you pro-life
[__] you you force birthers
it's time it's time you stand and it's
time we fight like we did in 2022.
you're going to see with this decision
all across the country confusion
you're going to see not just Walgreens
but CVS and all pharmacies everywhere
you think Walgreens was the enemy oh
baby wait until every Pharmacy can't
sell this [__] because the FDA can't let
them sell it
okay someone's saying Walgreens is
complicit listen their complicency their
complicency is going is only going to be
to follow the fda's regulations
and if the FDA cannot cannot let them
sell this drug they will not you know
how much Walgreens profits off this
medication how much CVS does
I'm telling you I'm telling you right
now if your focus if your focus is on
Walgreens or any private company
especially a pharmaceutical a pharmacy
out there that is actually going to
provide this drug to women
and not on the people who are trying to
strip away the right for women to have
access to this drug
you will lose this battle
we will lose
we will lose if we lose sight of who the
person who the people are that are the
enemy to women's [__] rights
it's time
it's time to know who the enemy is and
go after them we did it in 2022 we can
continue to [__] do it we could
continue to do it
but we cannot we cannot lose sight and
spend our energy and spend our energy we
can't
we can't spend our energy fighting
battles that aren't the battle to fight
we must use our national narrative
International messaging to push hard
against the people who are trying to
take away people's rights
it's time
it's time to do that and yes it feels
good to boycott someone who may who may
or may not
be providing this or not
time that we show who the real enemy is
if you want to boycott something if you
want a boycott you want to waste your
energy with the boycott boycott
Republicans
boycott Republican campaigns
Point them out show them for who they
are use your energy to get the narrative
in this country that they are trying to
strip away your [__] rights and they
aren't going to stop
they won't stop they're not going to
they won't
trust me on this
they're coming for it your Liberty
everyone thanks for joining me I know
you may disagree with me on my Walgreens
thing and that's cool that's fine that's
fine go boycott them go boycott them
spend your time writing the tweets spend
your time trying to um trying to make
Walgreens the scapegoat here that's
that's what Republicans want
they don't want you to talk about how
they're taking away your rights and
state houses taking away your parental
consent taking away your health care
they don't want that they want you to
scapegoat Walgreens that Walgreens is
the one taking away your health care
that's what they want that way they can
say ah we didn't take away your health
care that was Walgreens that did that
Walgreens did that do you think these
brainless imbeciles these megalodites
aren't going to buy that hook line
Sinker good luck to you everyone
come join me tomorrow seriously even if
you're mad about me mad at me about the
Walgreens thing come join me tomorrow
same time same place YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't forget to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast download every
single episode here at the Tony Michaels
podcast go file follow us on the up wire
go to the upwire.com you follow the
YouTube channel there follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels make sure
to link your Amazon Prime account to
Twitch give us a little bit of that Jeff
Bezos money give us the one free
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account
and as always
be watching for the bonehead poll
because tomorrow's Friday second hour
bone end of the week
same time same place we're gonna start
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
's mealborn headass Beacon